ukraine's capital kiev has come under
renewed attack as russia ramps up its
invasion now in its second day
air raid sirens have sounded in kiev
this morning and blasts were heard in
the hours before dawn
an apartment building was partially
destroyed after ukrainian forces said
they downed a russian fighter jet over
the capital
sirens have also been heard in the city
of the viv in western ukraine
the ukrainian government says at least
137 people have been killed and hundreds
wounded across the country
russia is continuing its air sea and
land assault which it launched in the
early hours of thursday morning
ukrainian president vladimir lenski says
the fate of europe is being decided in
his country
ukrainian soldiers on the outskirts of
the eastern city of kharkiv
inspecting just some of the carnage from
day one of russia's invasion of ukraine
then after dusk the destruction
continued
civilians took refuge in subway stations
looking for whatever safety they could
find
also in the ukraine capital kiev people
headed for the underground fearful
russia could launch airstrikes
i'm here because i think it's one of the
only places right now where you can hide
in kiev all the other places are
terrifying
at a strategic air base just 20
kilometers away from the capital reports
of russian forces and control
however ukraine says it prevented a
complete takeover of the facility
ukrainian troops have set up roadblocks
throughout the city's government quarter
late on thursday night ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky said he was
aware of the danger but that he was
remaining in the capital
according to our information the enemy
has listed me as target number one and
my family as target number two
they want to destroy the country
politically terminating the head of
state
satellite images also show the
destruction russia is raining down on
ukraine
here the damage to airfields and the
east of the
country and russia is proving it's not
only interested in military facilities
ukrainian officials confirmed they've
lost control of the decommissioned
chernobyl nuclear power plant
the scene of the world's worst nuclear
disaster is now in russian hands
dw correspondent matthias berlinger
joins me from kiev matthias city
residents have been spending the night
in air raid shelters there are reports
of explosions in the capital what is the
situation there right now
yeah people are coming slowly out of
these shelters now but as you can see
there are few people on the streets many
people have left the capital we've seen
these pictures of
long columns of of cars leaving the city
um
there was intense uh bombing last night
american intelligence says that russia
fired 160 rockets on ukraine and
part of them on the capital there was
also
air defense
destroying some of them we are not sure
now right now what exactly
happened but there were there were
clashes in the air when air defense hit
something and the debris fell down and
hit one residential building
people had been evacuated from there but
the building was burning and we don't
really know about casualties yet um
so uh the whole night there were there
were
there were attacks on the capital and uh
today there is the expectation that
russia will try to move with tanks onto
the capital again
can you give me an idea of the mood
among ukrainians the family members i've
spoken to are staying
many have been fleeing and others want
to fight
well
it's terror people are afraid of what's
going to happen next and they're trying
to do their best to to
protect themselves
if they don't enlist in the
forces we've also seen
uh pictures of people queuing up in
front of the recruitment bureaus of the
territorial defense forces that's the
volunteer
battalions that are supposed to act
behind the lines in support of
the
army and
we
know that they have been mobilized also
there are numerous reports that suggest
russia could enter the capital even in
the coming hours they've already taken
control as we mentioned of the chernobyl
area around 150 kilometers to the north
will they be met with resistance
the ukrainian ex
government expects them to come from two
sides north west and north east
and has announced fierce resistance what
we've seen so far is that the ukrainian
army has been countering this attack
quite forcefully they are
much
uh the the
russian army is of course in terms of
technology numbers and everything much
superior to the ukrainian but the
motivation to defend the country is
there and we've seen these battles
around the airfield that we've
mentioned before
where russia was able to almost take
control of it and then it has been it
seems to have been according to our
information that we have
now have been completely driven out
again so um there is of course a desire
to to defend the country and uh these uh
weapons that ukraine has received the
javelins
and the stingers of course they will be
put to use
mathias what about the situation in the
east which has been so
key to the fighting over the past eight
years
uh describe what you saw on on your
journey after returning from the east to
the capitol
well we left pretty early in the the we
left the east pretty early so we didn't
witness any of the fighting there there
were a bomb
yesterday morning there were rocket
artillery attacks um but we didn't see
them what we know now is that fighting
has intensified along the line of
contact with these self-proclaimed
claimed republics and uh also the city
of harcroft which is not part of the
donbass that part of the east that peop
that ukraine has
and the separatists backed by russia
have been fighting about for years but
one another region closer to russia this
has been also been under attack so
attacks on ukraine are happening from
all sides and from the south as well so
um we have reports of heavy fighting
everywhere matthias berlinga in kiev
thank you very much and stay safe
well we can go now to our russian
affairs analyst constantine egert he's
on the line from vilnius
the world is looking on in in disbelief
at these events in ukraine what's your
assessment of russia's standing in the
world
considering what's going on
not such a good morning uh ben and i
hope your relatives in ukraine are safe
uh i think that uh
in fact
these pictures uh that we've seen in the
last 24 hours uh rfpr disaster for the
government
uh i don't think that even during the uh
the yugoslav war of 1990
seen anything like that major european
city of nearly 3 million but across a
major european country 41 million
population largest
uh largest european country
wholly uh situated in europe so i
suppose also there is a very clear
um
well pr implication and all that if i
may sound silly
uh and that is that
ukraine wasn't taken in one blow we
don't see uh you know flowers and flags
that uh basically it seems like uh the
kremlin expected to see uh the
resistance is stiff matthias has noted
uh in the previous report from from here
that uh this is uh
of course a very unequal competition uh
between the ukrainian and russian army
but on the other hand
defenders always have an advantage
and motivation of course is quite high
uh among the ukrainian forces i cannot
even imagine what will happen uh if and
when the russian forces enter major
ukrainian cities we've seen what
happened in the in in chechnya in grozny
uh
in the north caucasus in russia in 1990s
we've seen that
aleppo held out in syria for about a
year against an air force uh onslaught
uh i wonder what will happen in keith
again i think it is already a pr
disaster for moscow and and if they do
manage to enter kiev
how quickly could the government there
fall
well it seems that
the
fall of the government is not on the
cards
because i do think that in such
circumstances i cannot penetrate the
thinking of the iranian government but i
would be quite surprised if they didn't
make any kind of arrangements for the
government to continue to operate from
other parts of ukraine probably from
western ukraine and actually what i
think is a possibility is that the uh
russian forces could strike at western
ukraine it seems
uh quite um unimaginable now it's also
because it is it borders nato it called
it poland uh and also because uh there's
a fierce kind of anti-moscow feeling
there but uh i suppose that uh
that
the korean government thought about it i
do not think that taking kia
is the ukrainians will call it uh will
mean the collapse of the ukrainian state
i do think that there was a provision
made for that and everything we've seen
in the last 24 hours show that the
structures of the state are still there
well apart from invading i mean the
russians would need to occupy some of
the country for some time to keep
any sort of
puppet government in in in place if if
that's what the intention is i mean we
we saw that with yanukovych of course he
was driven out by the ukrainians
well look uh i think i'm my my military
service is limited to
three years and i'm a first or first
lieutenant reserve but so i can't
pretend to be a military expert but
frankly speaking i think that occupation
force for a a a country of such size and
such population
needs to be really huge
russian army i think standing russian
army is about 1 million people
probably you will need most of it to
take over ukraine and maintain a
permanent occupation well
when putin said he doesn't intend to
occupy frame but then what's the point i
suppose that keeping uh the puppet
government well you can keep it in
probably in one place you can probably
control kiev uh but it will be very
difficult to imagine how this government
will uh will project its authority
across the country where i'm certain
there's going to be a guerrilla war
so i think it's
nearly mission impossible
uh that said how are russians viewing
this invasion
well i think that
what i've seen last uh night and all
through the last day
uh surprised me so there's going to be
much fewer protesters in
russia against the war what i've seen
actually in my native city of moscow uh
is
quite impressive okay it's a country a
country of 140 million people so um i
mean
it's not probably such a huge size but
one has to understand people fear people
are apathetic in russia so those who
went to the streets are very very brave
people and i think the current figure is
about the 1600 arrests but what looking
into the future what i can say this war
cannot be popular and each day that it
continues
will sap
support for this adventure uh whether it
will eventually turn into some kind of
elite pulling out between themselves or
mass demonstrations i don't know but it
will probably take time but i'm sure
it's not it's not popular
and as we heard from constantine there
there have been protests both in russia
and in ukraine constantine ergo thank
you very much for coming on the show
thank you
well european union leaders have agreed
to impose new sanctions on russia over
its war on ukraine but they held back
from cutting russia from the global
swift payment system
after resistance from some countries
european commission president also
fonder line says the agreed measures
would have a major impact on russia's
economy
we will hold the kremlin accountable
the package of massive and targeted
sanctions
european leaders approved tonight
clearly demonstrates that
it will have maximum impact on the
russian economy and the political elite
and it is built of five pillars the
first at the financial sector
second the energy sector the third is
the transport sector
fourth are export controls and the ban
of export financing and finally visa
policy
christine mahuntwa is in brussels for us
to talk about these sanctions another
round how far do they go though this
time
ben the european council president
charles michelle said that these
sanctions were massive and painful and
by all indications
they will be bent they will be felt by
ordinary russians as prices grow up
because of inflation ordinary household
items uh going up in prices
we can also expect ben that some
businesses will not survive uh as the
economy goes into recession because of
these sanctions beyond the sort of
medium-term impact this is also going to
effectively destroy industry some
industries in russia as as they're not
able to access certain technologies that
are required to power a modern day
future so it is certainly looking like
these sanctions will have an impact in
the medium term but also in the longer
term bin
christine we've had a whole raft of
sanctions now a whole series of them
from weak to strong and now massive but
the harshest of them all would be
cutting russia off from the
inter-banking system called swift but
we're hearing that germany and italy
held off on that why
that's right ben you've got to
understand that for all the sanctions
that are going to be imposed on the
russian economy uh they're also going to
hit european economies too and some more
than others for berlin and rome perhaps
there is self-interest
at play here for for for germany it is
of course uh those uh that dependence on
russian gas germany is a major russian
gas importer
for italy it's those increasing business
ties uh between italy and russia the
swift payment system is a messaging
system between banks ben and cutting
russia off of that would effectively
make it impossible to send money
to russia and out of russia and of
course that makes doing business with
russia difficult germany and italy have
been accused of pursuing self-interest
uh at a time where you you know lives
are at risk in fact the the ukrainian um
uh foreign minister uh hours before that
meeting anticipating that this would
happen say that anybody who wouldn't um
uh just a vote to to ban russia from
effectively had the blood of ukrainians
uh on their hands but there is also
another argument to this ben and that is
um that you've got to keep some leverage
um because if this goes into some kind
of a protracted war you've got to be
able to have some leverage to go to
moscow and and put something on the
table for so that as well is is a factor
that european leaders did consider i
understand the argument on leverage um i
i don't want to talk more about the the
business reasons behind this but but i
mean why hold back when russia really
isn't i mean that's
the strategy of putin's to uh go in um
and and um
not hold back i mean
watching europe holding back here is is
is really
unsettling i i have to say uh but before
i go on a rant let me uh just play to
you something the ukrainian president
said listen into this
yep
in all the many conversations i've had
with other leaders today i've heard
several things the first one is that
we're supported and i'm grateful to
every nation that helps ukraine in
concrete ways
but there is a second thing
we are alone in defending our nation
who is ready to fight with us
i don't see anybody
who is ready to give ukraine a guarantee
of joining nato
everyone is afraid
a very good question let me pose that
one to you christine is ukraine alone in
this fight against russia
we have to say yes uh ben that is the
reality um when the nato secretary
general jens stoltenberg briefed the
press yesterday
he confirmed that there were no combat
troops uh nato combat troops in ukraine
and that there were no plans to send any
to ukraine
so this is certainly
a fight the ukrainians are going to have
to
take on on their own we know that nato
is making plans um it has warships and
battleships on high alert it's given
special powers to its top commander he
can effectively uh deploy nato's
response force uh without having to go
through the procedure of consulting all
the 30 allies but this these provisions
ben have only been made for nato member
states and not for ukraine for ukraine
it is the promise of more political
support
more military aid going over to ukraine
and indeed we have seen some initiation
by some member states opting to send
more military aid as well as financial
donations to help the ukrainian army but
ukrainian soldiers will not be fighting
alongside western soldiers in this fight
this will be
their their own fight uh ben
christie melbourne for us brussels
correspondent great to have you on the
show as well
u.s president joe biden has also moved
to punish russia with fresh sanctions
saying he's convinced putin wants to
overthrow ukraine's democratically
elected government in a premeditated
attack
biden has ruled out military
intervention in ukraine but he did
affirm the u.s commitment to defending
its nato allies in eastern europe
and putin's aggression
against ukraine will end up costing
russia dearly
economically and strategically
we will make sure of that
putin will be a pariah on the
international stage
any nation the accountant is russia's
naked aggression against ukraine will be
stained by association
when the history of this era is written
putin's choice
to make a totally unjustifiable war on
ukraine will have left russia weaker
and the rest of the world stronger
liberty democracy human dignity these
are the forces far more powerful
than fear and oppression
they cannot be extinguished by tyrants
like putin and his armies
they cannot be erased by people from
people's hearts and hopes by any amount
of violence and intimidation
they endure
and let's bring in our correspondent in
washington stephen simon stefan
we heard president biden talk about
russia having to pay dearly for its
aggression against ukraine for president
zielinski the sanctions are not going
far enough and as we heard germany and
italy have their business interests to
think about could the u.s have done more
well i think you heard a president
actually who was trying to exert
leadership here and who was
kind of also desperate
to
keep the house of the west together a
unity is a key word here you know
if you leverage sanctions against russia
now you need to do this unified and as
soon as this unity
shows cracks
you'll have a problem and i think the
u.s administration u.s diplomats as well
as i think european governments realize
that so the president tried to exert
leadership here
speaking of the sanctions and the swift
program you know
it's fairly easy for russia to get
around the swift program so the
president actually alluded to this
because
the americans say they had actually told
all of the allies and partners that and
also told and foreseen what will happen
that russia will go for a big grab on
ukraine not just the donbass region now
i don't know if that's true but that's
at least what they claim so but um
could have
been done more to save ukraine
i don't know probably not there's a lot
of experts out there a lot of people are
a lot smarter than i am who say and who
have good reasons good arguments for
saying like this was
inevitable and they couldn't have done
anything more sanctions leveraged now
against russia
they are not preventing anything anymore
they are punishment and
and they are leveraged for future
possible negotiations i think okay yeah
stefan we're just looking at live
pictures of ukraine and the situation
right now which is a very sad situation
a bombed out building there the the us
has
ruled out military intervention in
ukraine but what more can it offer in
order to support the country
yeah troops on the ground
are boots on the ground definitely not
because ukraine is not a nato member and
of course the united states wants to
avoid and that is express this verb is
also
the president saying as well as
everybody else in his administration
that the us does not want
a war or a confrontation soldier against
soldier with the russians um the belief
is he also that the russians don't want
that either and actually are a little
bit afraid of that's going to happen so
but you have a a horrible situation in
ukraine and there is
really
no
clue offered by anybody what the u.s can
do actually to actively help
the ukraine now uh definitely not
militarily
more
weapons to get more weapons or weaponry
or weapon systems into the ukraine right
now
seems a little bit iffy at best i mean
if not even impossible um so moral
support and
maybe an increase in or a a
leveraging of more severe sanctions per
purse step by step in the next coming
days but uh but the u.s is sending over
more troops to neighboring nato members
we know that how how is the american
public feeling about that
yeah um we know that the americans send
seven thousand troops to germany uh and
from there they will be sent to uh other
uh nations to the eastern border of nato
so to speak um i can't tell you how
americans feel about this because
it's a little bit too early that was
yesterday that the president said that
um i knows though that the american
public now pays attention to what's
going on in ukraine but that's not
necessarily because the united states
says they're sending 7 000 troops that's
because the president said that every
american will feel the pain and that
means at the gas station the sticker
shock is coming to america and of course
mr biden realizes that this is not um
something which helps him politically
and in the eyes of the american people
stephen simons thank you very much for
the analysis from washington
you